Alle. Gut und arg mein Name ist Mehmet Yalin. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistenzartistin und hier die gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie? Natürlich gerne.
Heute bin ich für Sie zuständig, falls Sie mich nicht verständen können,
mit der Essimie Bescheid zu geben.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ich bin einverstanden.
Okay. Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Bescheiden sprechen,
muss ich Ihre persönlichen Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie denn? Mein Name ist Michael Schmidt.
Önten Sie Ihren voll und nachnahmenden Lärm, burschtabieren.
Mein Vormaimer M-I-C-H-A-E-L.
Mein Nachname ist Schmidt. S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau, Herr Schmidt?
42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
15. März 1982.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ein Mitte 78 groß und 82 Kilogramm.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Wo ich wohne?
Ja.
In München.
Könnten Sie mir den Namen ihres Hausarztes verraten?
Das ist der Herr Wolf, Dr. Wolf.
Okay. Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Herr Schmidt.
Was für Sie denn, so was für 5 verraten Sie?
Also ich bin heute in die Ambulanz gekommen, weil es mir sehr, sehr schlecht geht.
Ich habe überall Schmerzen, starke Husten.
Meine Kopfschmerzen sind so stark, dass mein Kopf gleich platzt.
Und ich habe sehr hohe Fieber.
Das tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter diesen Bechwerden?
Seit nun knapp 3 Tagen.
Okay. Haben Sie zu Hause das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe das jeden Tag gemessen.
Wie hoch war das?
39, manchmal knapp 40.
Können Sie genauer beschreiben, ob Sie trockenen Husten oder Reis Husten haben?
Der ist manchmal trocken, manchmal kommt er auch noch raus.
Aber er ist eher so ein trockener Husten, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Können Sie einen Auslöser für die Bechwerden ausmachen, Herr Schmidt?
Nein.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrem Kreis, eigentlich Bechwerden oder Reise?
Haben Sie gegend die Bechwerden irgendetwas angenommen, zum Beispiel Schmerz, Mittel?
Genau. Deshalb habe ich jetzt schon seit 2 Tagen einen genommen.
Was haben Sie?
Ich habe ein Ibupkofen und Paracita Mol angenommen.
Hast du diese Medikamente geholfen?
Es geht einigermaßen, aber nicht wirklich.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie schon erwähnt, dass Sie Kopfschmerzen haben?
Ja, das ist Kopfschmerzen.
Stark.
Können Sie mir zeigen, wo genaue
Die ganze Seite hier.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Nackensteifigkeit haben?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Nackensteifigkeit.
Ihr Nackensteif?
Der tut mich weh, nein.
Nein, okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalauffon 1?
Acht bis neun.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Für uns ist es abgeschlagen, oder müde?
Ja, total.
Bevor wir das laufendere Gespräch fortsetzen, möchte ich eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Vorher fällt Ihnen in diesem Zusammenhang etwas ein.
Sie wollten meine Zusammenfassung machen, oder?
Ich wollte.
Ja, machen Sie ruhig.
Sie fühlen sich abgeschlagen, außer dem haben Sie Fieber von 39, 40 Grad.
Gegen die Beschwerden haben Sie Ibuprofenalparacetamol eingenommen.
Hab ich alles richtig gesagt, oder möchten Sie etwas?
Nein.
Nun würde ich Ihnen noch ein paar Fragen stellen, um ein unfassendes Bild Ihrer Erkrankung zu haben.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten ab oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schüttefrost oder Nachtweite bemerkt?
Ja, in den letzten zwei Tagen habe ich schon ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Ich bin fieberbeschwitzig auch.
Bezogene Nacht oder ganz...
Auch.
Okay.
War Ihnen schwindelig oder wurde Ihnen schwarz worden?
Wenn ich aufstehe, wird mich schwindelig.
Okay, habe ich das notiert.
Haben Sie Atemnot bemerkt?
Fühlen Sie sich kursatmig?
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich nicht gut durchatmen kann.
Sind Ihnen Herzrausen, Herzklopfen oder ein unregelmäßiger Herzschlag aufgefallen?
Nein, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Herz schneller schlägt.
Ich habe Blutdruck gemessen, aber es war so wie 90 bis 100.
90 bis 100.
Der Herzschlag.
Okay.
Haben Sie Zotbiren, Alphastos oder Blühungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasalasen oder mit dem Sturrgang?
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind oder ihr war geschwollen ist?
Nein, Alphastos.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Schlaf Sie gut?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Sie oft aufwachen,
dass Sie sich seit Tagen mit starken Kopfschmerzen lassen.
Und natürlich rusten, wenn ich keine Luft kriege.
Haben Sie Veränderungen Ihrer Haut bemerkt?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ernähren Sie sich gesund und ausgewochen?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Schimit, ich komme zu Ihrer Erkrankung.
Gibt es bei Ihnen eine chronische Erkrankung,
von der ich wissen sollte?
Ich nenne Blutdruck-Bereikamente ein, von meinem Blutdruck.
Das war mir auch eine Familie bekannt.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Das ist schon seit vier Jahren ungefähr.
Seitdem ich 38 Jahre alt bin.
Gibt es sonst noch etwas?
Sonst habe ich keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Schimit?
Noch nie.
Das ist sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Nehmen Sie für den Blutdruck, nehm ich einmal morgens eine Kabelette ein.
Wissen Sie den Namen des Medikaments?
Wie sind Sie?
Wie sind Sie die Dosierung?
Hab ich nicht im Kopf.
Okay, kein Problem.
Sind Sie vorständig gegen Herr Schimit?
Ich glaube schon.
Gegen Corona auch, oder?
Ja, da hatte ich mich auch im Telenassen, also zur Corona-Zeit.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nun gegen Hausstraut.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie?
Mit Yukreis und Nies anfällen.
Besutlicht Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Rauchen Sie Herr Schimit?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und an.
Können Sie noch einmal sagen?
Trinken Sie und wie oft trinken Sie?
Vielleicht ein, zwei Mal im Monat, wenn ich mich mit meinen Freunden treffe.
Okay.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine.
Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Sie nehmen keine Drogen, nehmen Sie nicht.
Nein.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport oder bewegen Sie sich ausreichend?
Ich versuche, zwei Mal in der Woche ins Fitnessstudio zu gehen.
Das ist sehr für Ihre Gesundheit besonders.
Danke schön.
Okay Herr Schimit.
Nun möchte ich Ihnen mit Ihnen über Ihre Familie sprechen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Beide leben noch, ja.
Sie haben chronische Arterie, Bluthochdruck, oder?
Genau, Sie haben auch Bluthochdruck.
Mein Vater hat auch Diabetes.
Meine Mutter hat eine Schilddrösenproblem.
Mein Vater hat auch einen Ostattack-Artsynom gehabt.
Das ist aber ausgeheilt.
Wie sind Sie welchen Typ Diabetes meleitus?
Ihr Vater hat?
Also eine Tablette, nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Tabletten, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister Herr Schimit?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland Herr Schimit?
Ich war nicht letzte Zeit, ich war im Herbst im Ausland.
Seit wann waren Sie dort?
Im Herbst.
Also für fünf Monate oder?
Ja, drei Monate.
Sie sind fünf Monate im Sommer.
Drei Monate im Herbst.
Ich bin fast fertig mit dem Aufnahmegespräch, Herr Schimit.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich habe eine Frau und eine Tochter.
Ist Ihre Tochter gesund?
Sie ist gesund, ja.
Sie hat keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bürokaufmann.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im alltäglichen Leben?
Wie jeder andere auch.
Okay, Herr Schimit.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Wald?
Nein.
Nein, ich mache es nicht.
Ich bin fertig mit dem Aufnahmegespräch.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich bin sehr besorgt.
Ich brauche etwas, das mir besser geht.
Ich höre Ihnen sehr dankbar sein, wenn Sie mir zügig helfen würden.
Ich habe mich sehr dankbar.
Ich habe mich sehr dankbar, wenn Sie mir zügig helfen würden.
Wir sind für Sie da.
Wir kümmern sich um Sie.
Meine Tochter hat Geburtstag in drei Tagen.
Ich muss wieder fit werden.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Ich muss Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich muss Sie ein wenig Blut abnehmen.
Ich muss Sie ein bisschen untersuchen.
Ich muss Sie eine feste Diagnose stellen.
Ich werde eine Behandlung geben.
Was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Ich habe gesagt, dass Sie etwas sagen.
Was Ihnen für das Erste haben immer drei Schritte.
Aufnahmegespräch, körperliche Unterzüge,
und Bilgewende, Verfahren.
Wir haben jetzt aufnahmegespräch beendet.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse voll sind,
informiere ich Sie sofort.
Das ist zu früh.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich bedanke mich.
Ich habe sehr stark Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel.
Aber vorher haben Sie ein Allergie gegen den Schmerzmittel.
Nicht das Schmerzmittel.
Sie bekommen gleich eines.
Ein Enjektor, ein Injektion.
Ein Schmerzmittel.
Ein Schmerzmittel mit einem
Venezium-Wert.
Ein Schmerzmittel mit einem Venezium-Wert.
Ich denke, es war eine gute Patiente.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie vor drei Tagen Erkältung oder Grippe?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Vor drei Tagen haben Sie andere Erkrankungen.
Erkältung oder Grippe?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich es habe.
Kopfschmerzen, Fieber, Muskelschmerzen.
Aber seit drei Tagen haben Sie es?
Vor drei Tagen?
Keine.
Meinen Sie davor?
Ja.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Wenn ich wusste, habe ich Schmerzen.
Ich habe keine Gelddurchsage.
Fühlen Sie sich schläfig?
Nein, aber ich bin sehr müde.
Ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen.
Hatte Kopfschmerzen plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, die sind seit zwei Tagen da.
Ich fühle mich seit drei Tagen nicht gut.
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich sehr stark Kopfschmerzen.
Wie ist es?
Es ist gefragt worden.
Ach, das ist neu.
Ich habe die Frage gefragt.
Wie ist die Erste-Geschichte?
Ja.
Ich habe eine Vorstellung.
Wie ist die Erste-Geschichte?
Okay.
Mein Name ist Mehmet Yalin.
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit zweieinhalb Jahren lebe ich in Deutschland.
Ich habe Medizin an der Universität von Ankara abgeschlossen.
Und dort ungefähr acht Jahre gearbeitet.
Ich bin verheiratet.
Als Hausarzt und Notfallarzt.
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Darf ich Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, bitte.
Es geht um Herrn Michael Schmidt.
Er ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß und 82 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns wegen
der Erste-Geschichte seit drei Tagen
für die Erste-Geschichte.
Darüber hinaus fügt der Patient hinzu,
dass sie 40 Grad süß ist.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns wegen der Erste-Geschichte seit drei Tagen
für die Erste-Geschichte seit 3 Tagen
und diese Medikamente habe ihm nicht besonders geholfen.
Der Patient schwitze in der letzten Zeit vermerkt.
Verner seien den Patienten eine Inapätenz und eine beschwerde bedingte Insomni Auffgefallen.
An vorherkrankungen nannte der Patient seit vier Jahren Bechteende Arterellehypertoni.
Er nahm regelmäßig die Zinopiril einmal morgens.
Er sei noch nie operiert worden.
Der Patient sei vollständig geheim.
Bei ihm sei eine Hausstau allergiebekannt, die sich prioritisiert.
Besüglich der Lebensgewohnheiten teilte der Patient mit,
ein bis zweimal im Monat zu trinken.
Ein Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneins.
Er gehe regelmäßig zweimal der Wohe Fitnessstudio.
Die Familienanamnese ergab einen Diabetes mellitus, Arterelleblutuchtruk
und Prostata carcinoma bimphata, eine Arterellehypertoni
und eine Tröiderkrankung bei ihrer Mutter.
Der Patient sei in der letzten Zeit nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Der Patient sei verheiratet und habe eine Tochter, die gesund ist.
Der Patient sei Bürokaufmann von Beruf und habe nicht besonderen Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er hat Beschwerden beim Wasserlasten oder Sturren?
Er hatte keine Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlasten oder mit dem Sturren.
War er schon beim Hausarzt gewesen?
Das habe ich Ihnen nicht gefragt.
Was haben Sie für eine Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Anamnesterischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Influencer hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen die folgenden Diagnosen in Betracht.
Covid-19, Erkrankung.
Seit drei Tagen hat der Patient diese Beschwerden.
Er hat keine Risikofaktoren davon.
Ich denke nicht, dass er eine Pneumonie hat, aber es könnte auch sein.
Was machen Sie jetzt diagnostisch?
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen, ihre Vitalparameter messen.
Dann werde ich die folgenden Blutuntersuchungen anfordern.
Blutbild, Serum, Ensyndumsparameter, WSRP, oder BSG.
Neerumverte, Serum, Elektrolyte und Leberverte auch.
Ich werde eine Blutkultur veranlassen.
Eine Torax-Grafie.
Eine EKG.
Eine EKG-Mitgmachung.
Blutkultur ist gut.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf?
Sollte die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen werden, würde ich den Patienten nicht stationär aufnehmen.
Wie können Sie den Bestätigen den Verdacht?
Vielleicht sind die PCR-Tests in Ordnung.
Die Testen sind ja auch automatisch.
Ja, auch automatisch.
Was ist das für eine Schnell-Test?
Eine Schnell-Test.
Wie bei Covid.
Ein Abstich machen.
Man kann einen Abstich machen und dann kann man gucken, ob das Influencer ist oder kein Influencer ist.
Ist das eher Influencer A oder Influencer B?
Was ist das wahrscheinlich?
Influencer B, glaube ich.
Die Ansteckende Art ist meistens Influencer A, aber es kann auch B sein.
Aber in der Regel ist es sehr oft Influencer A in seinem Alter.
Vielleicht ist ein Kind krank, hat er nicht gesagt, weil er jemand anderen eingesteckt hat.
Wahrscheinlich hat er eine Influencer.
Man kann diesen Patienten stationär aufnehmen, wenn es ihm sehr schlecht geht.
Er berichtet, dass er Kopfschmerzen hat, sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Und er hat gesagt, Ibuprofen und Parastamol haben nicht richtig geholfen.
Man kann den Patienten ein paar Tage stationär aufnehmen und den Patienten in der Therapie machen.
Was kann man noch geben?
Medikament oder antivirale Therapie würde ich fera bryan?
Was würden Sie geben?
Asikovir oder Tamsulovir?
Ja, genau.
So etwas kann man machen.
Wenn es ein Influencer A ist, aber wenn es ein Influencer ist.
Und was würden Sie machen, wenn Sie den Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Was muss man mit diesem Patienten machen?
Auf jeden Fall isoliert sich die Patienten.
Sehr gut.
Gibt es Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Warum denken Sie, Herr Müffel ist im Influencer A?
Könnten Sie erklären?
Lieberte?
Herr Müffel ist im Influencer A.
Warum Influencer?
Die Influencer A ist die häufige Revision, die Auftritt und die ansteckende Revision hier in Deutschland.
Seine Beschwerden sind typisch für eine Influencer Infektion.
Plötzlich aufgetreten, es geht ihm sehr schlecht.
Kopfschmerzen, Hochkardikfieber, Schlapp.
Das ist typisch für eine Grippe bzw. eine Influencer.
Welche Tests in Deutschland müssen wir durchführen, Herr?
Influencer Tests.
Zusammen drei Versionen, was heißt?
Covid mit...
Die gibt es noch nicht, ich weiß nicht genau.
Aber es gibt einen Covid-Test und Influencer-Test.
Man kann auch einen Bluttest machen, wie der Kollege gesagt hat.
Man kann es im Blut nachweisen, ob ein Influencer da ist oder nicht.
Aber im Krankenhaus muss man das sofort wissen, an Besten.
Wenn man den Patienten stationär aufnehmen möchte, ob man den isoliert oder nicht isoliert.
Deswegen ein Abstich machen.
Das geht am schnellsten.
Wir sind momentan in einer Grippesaison, wo Influencer sehr oft auftreten kann.
Zusammen mit der Corona- oder RSV Infektion.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?